violentas protestas acuden desde ayer
Paraguay simpatizantes de paraguayo Cuba
es el candidato antisistema que en las
elecciones consiguió un espectacular 22%
salieron a la calle en varias ciudades
del país para protestar contra un
supuesto fraude electoral comenzaron en
Ciudad del este la ciudad donde Cuba se
acabó su campaña electoral y aquí en
Asunción se congregaron numerosos frente
al tribunal superior de justicia
electoral y hubo momentos de tensión con
varios periodistas atacados y
patrulleras quemadas de hecho de momento
hay un saldo de al menos 54 detenidos
las protestas también afectaron al
tránsito de los autobuses por lo menos
1500 personas no pudieron regresar a
Asunción personas que habían viajado
durante el puente o para votar fuera de
su ciudad Mientras tanto el líder de la
coalición de Centro izquierda que perdió
las elecciones Efraín alegre también se
ha sumado a las rei y ha pedido que se
revisen manualmente al menos el 10% de
los votos recordamos que Paraguay tiene
un sistema de Voto electrónico donde el
elector puede imprimir la papeleta y
chequear dos veces que el voto
depositado sea correcto sin embargo ese
sistema su cita ciertas desconfianzas en
la población en el telón de fondo
siempre las acusaciones de que hay
compraventa de votos en los propios
colegios electorales el tribunal
superior de justicia electoral ha
anunciado hoy Que va a mostrar en
directo como se fiscalizan las actas
para ofrecer más transparencia a la
población